Hello.
你好。
Hi. This is Yousef Hammash?
你好。你是尤瑟夫·哈马什（Yousef Hammash）吗？
Yes, it is, loud and clear.
是的，我是，声音很清楚。
Good. [LAUGHS] Is this still a OK time for you to talk?
太好了。[笑] 现在方便和你谈谈吗？
Yes.
是的。
OK.
好的。
Yeah, but it's a bit crazy outside, a lot of crowds. There's a lot of traffic, especially from the children. Let me find a quiet place. Close the door. Yes.
是的，但外面有点乱，人很多。交通非常拥堵，尤其是孩子。让我找个安静的地方。关上门。好了。
Earlier this month, one of our producers, Chana Joffe-Walt, made this call to Yousef Hammash in Gaza. He works for a humanitarian organization, the Norwegian Refugee Council, the NRC. Yousef's in his early 30s, has got two kids, big extended family. Chana talked to him a few times over the course of one week, really knowing very little about him or his situation at the beginning.
本月初，我们的制片人查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）给加沙的尤瑟夫·哈马什打了这个电话。他在一家人道主义组织——挪威难民理事会（NRC）工作。尤瑟夫三十出头，有两个孩子，有一个庞大的大家庭。查娜在一周内和他通了几次电话，起初对他本人或他的处境知之甚少。
And as you'll hear, more and more unfolds and gets revealed. And it all feels so immediate and particular to these few weeks right now, in the war in Gaza, that we wanted to bring it to you now. Like, it feels like it's about right now. We have other stories, I should say, about this war in the works, including from inside Israel, so please stay tuned for those.
正如你即将听到的，随着时间的推移，越来越多的情况浮出水面。这一切对于当下加沙战争的这几周来说，感觉如此直接且特殊，所以我们想现在就呈现给你们。感觉就像是关于此时此刻的事情。我应该说，我们还在制作关于这场战争的其他故事，包括来自以色列境内的报道，请持续关注。
But for today, with Yousef, Chana would talk to him at night, his time. His family was living in the NRC office, in Rafah. So he was in the unusual situation in Gaza where he often did have internet access with solar panels providing power. The first day Chana talked to him, he had just relocated with his wife and kids to Rafah, where the office was. It's along the border with Egypt. His four sisters and their families were about eight miles away in a town called Khan Yunis. So here are those conversations.
但今天，关于尤瑟夫，查娜是在他那边的晚上和他通话的。他的家人住在拉法（Rafah）的挪威难民理事会办公室里。因此，他在加沙处于一种罕见的情况，即他经常有互联网连接，而且有太阳能电池板提供电力。查娜第一次和他交谈时，他刚和妻子孩子搬到拉法的办公室，那里靠近埃及边境。他的四个姐妹和她们的家人住在约8英里外一个叫汗尤尼斯（Khan Yunis）的城镇。下面就是这些对话。
So talk to me about what did you do today.
跟我说说你今天做了什么。
Today, I had to find a place for my extended family, which hamdullah, I found it today. I found a place, and I built a tent-- two tents, actually-- because I couldn't find a house to rent or anything. So tomorrow, I will move the rest of my family here to Rafah from Khan Yunis to these two tents. And today, it takes me a while, building these tents. Then I have to go to the market buying whatever I can find.
今天，我必须为我的大家庭找个地方，感谢真主，我今天找到了。我找到了一个地方，并搭了一个帐篷——实际上是两个——因为我找不到房子租或任何别的地方。所以明天，我会把剩下的家人从汗尤尼斯搬到拉法的这两个帐篷里。今天搭这些帐篷花了我不少时间。然后我得去市场买任何我能找到的东西。
What did you find?
你找到了什么？
Today, I found-- ah, that's a good question. Trying to remember. So some vegetables. Actually, it was tomato and pepper. And I couldn't find potato, because there is no potato in all over Gaza, and milk for the children. I'm responsible for my children, my sisters, my mother because I'm the only son here in Gaza. I'm the only man for a big family. So I have a quite big responsibility towards them, so.
今天，我找到了——啊，这是个好问题。我在努力回忆。是一些蔬菜。其实是西红柿和辣椒。我没能找到土豆，因为整个加沙都没有土豆，还有给孩子们喝的牛奶。我负责照顾我的孩子、姐妹和母亲，因为我是这里唯一的儿子。我是这个大家庭里唯一的男人。所以我肩负着相当大的责任。
Have you had decisions that you had to make for everybody that you couldn't figure out what the right choice was?
有没有什么决定是你不得不为大家做的，但你却不知道哪个选择才是正确的？
Yes. Yeah, that decision that I'm taking today. I decided to build a tent while they are in an apartment in Khan Yunis, and everything is available for them. I'm taking them in this harsh weather in an empty land under a tent.
有。是的，我今天做的这个决定就是。我决定搭个帐篷，而他们现在住在汗尤尼斯的一间公寓里，一切都应有尽有。我却要把他们带到这恶劣天气下的空地上，住在帐篷里。
I don't know if it's going to be right or wrong. I had to make this decision several times, unfortunately. Now, it became our routine is like now I have to move again, so. And it's not easy decision. And I was trying to evaluate the situation on a daily basis.
我不知道这是对还是错。不幸的是，我不得不多次做出这样的决定。现在，这成了我们的日常，就像现在我不得不再次搬迁一样。这不是一个容易的决定。我一直试图每天评估局势。
Is there anybody in the family that is hesitant? Do you have to--
家里有没有人犹豫不决？你必须——
Yes, we have had-- I had. Yes, yes. Yeah, yeah, eh, they are part of the family. Yeah, even a few minutes ago, I was having this debate with my sister that was like, OK, I'm pregnant, because she's pregnant. And she don't want to do the delivery in a tent. And she said, OK, they are still far, like 1 kilometer away, the tanks.
有，我们遇到过——我有过。是的，是的。是的，他们也是家庭的一员。是的，就在几分钟前，我还和我的姐妹争论，她说，好吧，我怀孕了，因为她怀孕了。她不想在帐篷里分娩。她说，好吧，坦克还在远处，大约1公里外。
And she said that we cannot suffer more. At least we have here bathroom. The main debate was a bathroom, about having your privacy to use a bathroom. Because when you are fleeing in a tent, there is no bathrooms or that privacy. Well, I'm trying-- tomorrow, I'll find a way to build a bathroom for them.
她说我们不能再受苦了。至少我们这里有浴室。主要的争论是关于浴室的问题，关于使用浴室是否有隐私。因为当你逃难住在帐篷里时，是没有浴室或隐私可言的。嗯，我在尝试——明天，我会想办法为她们建一个浴室。
This week that I'm talking to Yousef, it isn't the first time he's moved and convinced his sisters to move, too. They started the war in Jabalia, in the northern part of Gaza on October 7, when Hamas attacked southern Israel and killed around 1,200 people, the majority civilians in their homes, at work, enjoying a music festival, took about 240 people hostage. Yousef immediately moved his family from Jabalia to his parents' house in a nearby city, Beit Lahiya. They moved the very next day, October 8. It seemed safer there.
我与尤瑟夫交谈的这一周，并不是他第一次搬迁并说服他的姐妹们也搬迁。战争开始时，即10月7日哈马斯袭击以色列南部并杀害约1200人（大多数是平民，当时他们在家中、工作中，或在参加音乐节，约240人被扣为人质）时，他们正住在加沙北部的贾巴利亚（Jabalia）。尤瑟夫立即将家人从贾巴利亚搬到了附近城市拜特拉希亚（Beit Lahiya）他父母的房子里。他们在第二天，即10月8日就搬了。那里看起来更安全。
On October 9, Israeli airstrikes hit Jabalia, and then again on October 12, 19, 22, and 31, November 1, 2, 4, and on. Jabalia now has massive craters several yards deep. Yousef, his family, and his sisters had all fled to various relatives and friends in the north, until Israel told people in the north to move south. They had cousins in Khan Yunis, in the south of Gaza. So he and his family drove there and convinced his sisters to come, too. He says on the way, the cars in front of them and behind them were bombed.
10月9日，以色列空袭了贾巴利亚，之后在10月12日、19日、22日、31日以及11月1日、2日、4日又进行了空袭。贾巴利亚现在有几个码深的大坑。尤瑟夫、他的家人和他的姐妹们都逃到了北方的亲戚和朋友家，直到以色列告诉北方的人向南撤离。他们在加沙南部的汗尤尼斯有表亲。于是他和家人开车去了那里，并说服他的姐妹们也过来。他说在路上，他们前后方行驶的汽车都被炸毁了。
In Khan Yunis, they stayed with relatives, Yousef and his wife and his mom and his kids and his sisters and their families. Everyone stayed with cousins and relatives in different apartments across the city, until Yousef read a leaflet that fell from the sky. It said, you must evacuate immediately and go to shelters in the city of Rafah. The city of Khan Yunis is a dangerous combat zone. Forewarned is forearmed. It was signed the Israeli Defense Forces. That's when he fled to Rafah with his wife and his kids.
在汗尤尼斯，他们和亲戚住在一起，尤瑟夫、他的妻子、妈妈、孩子，还有他的姐妹和她们的家人。每个人都和亲戚挤在城里不同的公寓里，直到尤瑟夫读到一张从天而降的传单。传单上说，你们必须立即撤离，去拉法市的避难所。汗尤尼斯市是一个危险的战区。有备无患。落款是以色列国防军。就在那时，他带着妻子和孩子逃往拉法。
By that point, over 15,000 people in Gaza had been killed, the majority civilians. The place Yousef works, the NRC, had rented an office in Rafah, in the area the Israelis were now saying was a safe zone. Yousef moved his immediate family into the office, where he was when I called him, where he is now, in Rafah. But his sisters and their families aren't so sure they want to follow this time. So Yousef, from the moment he got to Rafah, has been pushing his sisters in Khan Yunis to come. He's been at that for almost a week.
到那时，加沙已经有超过15000人丧生，其中大部分是平民。尤瑟夫工作的挪威难民理事会在拉法租了一间办公室，那个区域当时被以色列人称为安全区。尤瑟夫把他的直系亲属搬进了办公室，这就是我给他打电话时他所在的地方，也是他现在所在的拉法。但他的姐妹和她们的家人这次不太确定要不要跟过来。所以尤瑟夫从到达拉法的那一刻起，就一直在敦促在汗尤尼斯的姐妹们过来。他已经为这事忙了快一周了。
To be honest, each one of them have its own personality, and I have to persuade her the way I know, each one of them. One of them, she's worried about her father-in-law and mother-in-law. And I was like, OK, they are not safe, and they are on the street. I'll build them a tent. But I want to make sure that you are with me here. I'll bring them also. The other one, I had to do the same option with her. OK, I'll bring your father-in-law and their entire family. I'll take care of them, but I want you to come here.
老实说，她们每个人都有自己的个性，我必须用我知道的方式去说服她们，每个人都不同。其中一个担心她的公公婆婆。我说，好吧，他们不安全，他们正待在街上。我会为他们搭个帐篷。但我必须确保你和我在一起。我也会把他们带过来。另一个姐妹，我也得用同样的办法。好吧，我会带上你的公公婆婆和他们全家。我会照顾他们，但我希望你过来。
What about the woman who's pregnant?
那个怀孕的女士呢？
I keep doing-- yeah, the woman pregnant, she's the youngest, and she's the most stubborn one. Yeah, she's the youngest. When we came to the south, there was no military operation on the ground. She refused, and her father-in-law and mother-in-law refused. I had a fight with them. And I told them, listen, I want my sister with me. And we had a bit of argue because they didn't expect what's coming.
我一直在——是的，怀孕的那位，她是最小的，也是最固执的。是的，她是最小的。当我们来到南部时，地面上还没有军事行动。她拒绝了，她的公公婆婆也拒绝了。我和他们吵了一架。我告诉他们，听着，我想要我的姐妹和我在一起。我们争论了一番，因为他们没预料到即将发生的事情。
Yeah, hadn't thought about how, each time, you have to mentally convince yourself that the place that you're in, which is feeling OK at that moment, might not feel OK very soon.
是的，我之前没想过，每次你都必须在心理上说服自己，你所处的那个当时感觉还不错的地方，可能很快就会变得不安全。
Yeah, and who would ever imagine that the Israeli tanks will be in the center of Jabalia camp? Or who would ever imagine that they would be in Shifa Hospital? Yeah, these things, we never imagined that it would be a real thing that we are seeing by our own eyes. We never thought about that.
是的，谁能想到以色列坦克会开进贾巴利亚难民营的中心地带？或者谁能想到它们会开进希法医院（Shifa Hospital）？是的，这些事情，我们从未想过会变成亲眼所见的现实。我们从未想过这些。
Yousef was lobbying his sisters to move as hard as he could, but honestly, he himself wasn't always totally sure about bringing them to Rafah. The evacuation order, it wasn't for all of Khan Yunis. There was no available housing in Rafah, not that he could find. In Khan Yunis, they had mattresses, a bathroom. And his sisters had moved cities twice already with kids, in-laws. So maybe they were fine.
尤瑟夫尽其所能游说他的姐妹们搬迁，但说实话，他自己并不总是完全确定带她们去拉法就是正确的。撤离令并不是针对整个汗尤尼斯。拉法没有可用的住房，至少他找不到。在汗尤尼斯，他们有床垫，有浴室。而且他的姐妹们已经带着孩子和公婆搬过两次城市了。所以也许她们在那里还好。
But then, Yousef says, he heard the Israeli military was now in a part of Khan Yunis he'd been staying in with his family, just a few days before. So maybe they weren't fine. Yousef kept searching for new information. He'd ask everyone he met, look everywhere online, except a few places he avoided.
但后来，尤瑟夫说他听说以色列军队现在就在他几天前带家人待过的那个汗尤尼斯区域。所以也许她们并不安全。尤瑟夫一直在搜寻新的信息。他会问遇到的每个人，查看网上的每一个地方，除了他刻意避开的几个网站。
I don't open my Facebook, for example, or Instagram because all my friends from Gaza are there because I don't want to know who's dead. I don't want to know. And I don't have the time to respect these people who I lose.
比如，我不打开我的Facebook或Instagram，因为我所有的加沙朋友都在那里，我不想知道谁死了。我不想知道。我也没有时间去哀悼那些我失去的人。
By coincidence, a few days ago, I found out that my uncle is dead. I didn't know about that before. And a friend of mine told me that. Oh, hey, you know, and, yeah. We were just having a chat, and I mentioned him. And he didn't know that he's my uncle. And I was talking that he's my uncle. And he's like, I'm sorry for your loss. I was like, what?
巧合的是，几天前，我发现我的叔叔去世了。在那之前我不知道。一个朋友告诉我的。哦，嘿，你知道，是的。我们当时正在聊天，我提到了他。他不知道那是我叔叔。我说他是我叔叔，他说，很遗憾听到这个消息。我说，什么？
Aw.
啊。
I didn't know. And it was like two weeks ago. He's dead. He's killed two weeks ago in Jabalia while I didn't know.
我不知道。那已经是两周前的事了。他死了。他在两周前的贾巴利亚空袭中丧生，而我竟然不知道。
How did that come up in that conversation?
在那种谈话中是怎么提到这件事的？
We were mentioning where his parents living in Jabalia. And I was like, OK, my relatives living there. They are from Ajouri family. And he was like, yeah, I know them. I was like, yeah, he's my uncle. He's like, yeah, sorry for your loss. I was like, no, no, no, he's alive. No, he was killed in an airstrike. I know, I know. And I feel a bit stupid. And it was a really weird feeling that I didn't know that my uncle is dead since two weeks. He was killed.
我们提到了他的父母住在贾巴利亚哪里。我说，好吧，我的亲戚住在那儿。他们是Ajouri家族的。他说，是的，我认识他们。我说，是的，他是我叔叔。他说，是的，很遗憾听到这个消息。我说，不，不，不，他还活着。不，他在空袭中丧生了。我知道，我知道。我觉得自己有点傻。那种感觉真的很奇怪，我竟然两周了都不知道我叔叔死了。他是被炸死的。
Do you--
你——
The other thing-- OK, just to continue on this story.
另外一件事——好吧，继续这个故事。
Please.
请讲。
Yesterday, my brother who lives in Sweden, my cousin who is the son of my uncle I mentioned, he was asking my brother to check if I have information about his father. And I don't want to be that-- also to deliver the news for him that his father was killed.
昨天，我在瑞典的哥哥，还有我提到的那位叔叔的儿子，我的表弟，他在请我哥哥确认一下他父亲的情况。我不想成为那个人——也不想告诉他父亲已经被杀的消息。
Have you told him?
你告诉他了吗？
No, I told him there is no connection between the south and the north, and it's impossible to reach anyone there, which is true, because there is no phone call. There is nothing that-- you cannot reach anyone in the north. And I was like, I will try to check what's the situation, but I couldn't-- I didn't want to be the one who's giving the news.
没有，我告诉他南部和北部之间没有联系，不可能联系到任何人，这是事实，因为没有电话。什么都没有——你无法联系到北部的任何人。我说，我会尝试核实情况，但我没能做到——我不想成为那个传达这个消息的人。
Oh, Yousef, so you just couldn't bring yourself to tell him what you had heard.
噢，尤瑟夫，你只是没法让自己说出你听到的消息。
Yes. Even my mother, who's with me now, doesn't know.
是的。甚至我母亲，她现在和我在一起，也不知道。
Is it her brother?
那是她的兄弟吗？
Yes.
是的。
And you're not going to tell her?
你不打算告诉她吗？
Definitely not. And I'm saying that here because I'm sure that-- they don't understand English, first of all, and second thing, they won't listen. Sorry for that, but they're in Gaza. They won't listen to this podcast to know from this podcast that-- yeah.
绝对不会。我在这里说出来是因为我确信——首先他们听不懂英语，其次，他们不会听。对此很抱歉，但他们在加沙。他们不会听这个播客，不会从播客里知道这件事——是的。
And another time that my brother-in-law, his sister was killed with her seven children. Also, they called me because they had his family reached out to me because they cannot reach him and asked me to tell him that his sister was killed with her entire family. And that was painful. It wasn't easy. I don't want to be in that position again.
还有一次，我妹夫的姐妹和她的七个孩子都被杀了。他们也给我打电话，因为他的家人联系不到他，请求我告诉他他的姐妹全家都被杀了。那真的很痛苦。那并不容易。我不想再处于那种位置了。
I always don't-- ya'ani, it's one of the first times that I really speak about these things, and it seems really weird for me that I always in front of everyone around me, I'm the man who's managing everything and supporting anyone in need. And if you need anything, the best one to call is Yousef, you know. Now I'm helpless, useless. And I cannot do anything. I cannot even manage my own need.
我总是——也就是，这是我第一次真正谈论这些事情，对我来说这似乎很奇怪，因为在周围人面前，我一直是那个处理一切、支持任何有需要的人的人。如果你需要什么，最好的联系人就是尤瑟夫，你知道。现在我感到无助、没用。我什么也做不了。我甚至无法解决自己的需求。
So if your uncle comes up, your mom mentions him or your wife says, oh, I wonder how he's doing, you will not say anything.
所以如果提到你叔叔，你妈妈提起他或者你妻子说，哦，不知道他怎么样了，你也不会说什么吗？
It happens, and I didn't say anything. Yes, it happened yesterday, and I was like, no, I am not going to say anything. My brain was like circling around. And I was like, OK, you have to tell her. She deserved to know that her brother is dead. And I was like, no. It's her right to know, and she will blame me a lot when she knows that I was knowing without telling her. I have to shut down my brain. It's like, no, you turn off. It's not your role now.
发生过这种情况，我什么也没说。是的，昨天刚发生过，我想，不，我不能说任何话。我的大脑一直在打转。我想，好吧，你得告诉她。她有权知道她的兄弟去世了。我又想，不行。她有权知道，但当她知道我明明知道却没告诉她时，她会很责怪我的。我不得不关闭我的大脑。就像，不，你关掉。现在不是你的角色。
Not your what?
不是你的什么？
It's not your role.
不是你的角色。
Not your role.
You don't need to be functioning now.
你现在不需要运作。
Mm-hmm, yeah. Focus on building tents.
嗯，是的。专注于搭帐篷。
Yeah, I have to be honest. I have plenty of to-do list. On my list is many things. My priority now, it's the time to secure my family and manage their needs more than anything else. For me, looking for their safety, it's not about them only. It's more about me. I cannot imagine, for a moment, losing one of them, one of my sisters. It has to be me before them.
是的，说实话。我有很多待办事项。我的清单上有很多事情。我的首要任务现在是保证家人的安全并处理他们的需求，胜过一切。对我来说，寻求他们的安全，不仅仅是为了他们。更是为了我自己。我无法想象哪怕一刻，失去他们中的一个，失去我的一个姐妹。必须是我走在她们前面。
I see.
我明白了。
'Cause I don't have the strength even to think about losing one of them. That's why I'm doing it. Not because of you, it's because of me. I don't have that. I am weak to have the strength to handle losing any one of them. I don't have that strength.
因为我甚至没有力量去想失去她们中的任何一个。这就是我这么做的原因。不是为了你们，是为了我。我没有那个能力。我太软弱了，没有力量承受失去她们中任何一人的打击。我没有那种力量。
Do you think they do it for you?
你认为她们是为了你才这样做的吗？
They came to Khan Yunis with me for me. No one agreed. It was really hard. And I had to fight with my mother. But they came because I want them. I want them to be with me.
她们跟着我到汗尤尼斯是为了我。没人同意。那真的很难。我不得不和我的母亲吵了一架。但她们来了，因为我需要。我想要她们和我在一起。
So they do it for you.
所以她们是为了你才做的。
At that time, yes. It was for me.
在那时候，是的。是为了我。
And this time?
那这次呢？
This time, I think I'll prepare everything. I will prepare the tents. I'll find you a place. Then I'll move you once, when everything's ready to have you. And what pushed me to finish everything today is that Benjamin Netanyahu, he was threatening Hezbollah. He was saying, Hezbollah, you should stop what you are doing because if you start a war, we will turn Beirut into Gaza and Khan Yunis. So I was like, OK, now it's Khan Yunis. I need to evacuate them from there. They are in the center of Khan Yunis.
这次，我想我会准备好一切。我会准备好帐篷。我会帮你找个地方。然后，我会把你们迁过来一次，当一切准备就绪的时候。今天促使我完成所有这一切的是，本雅明·内塔尼亚胡（Benjamin Netanyahu）在威胁真主党。他说，真主党，你们应该停止现在的行动，因为如果你们发起战争，我们将把贝鲁特变成加沙和汗尤尼斯。所以我想，好吧，现在轮到汗尤尼斯了。我需要把她们从那里撤离。她们就在汗尤尼斯的中心。
Did you send them that quote?
你把那句话发给她们了吗？
Yep. Because a lot of people stay until the last moment, and when they evacuate, they will evacuate under bombing. And I don't want my sisters to experience that.
是的。因为很多人会留到最后一刻，当他们撤离时，他们会在轰炸下撤离。我不想让我的姐妹们经历那种事。
What does the tent look like?
帐篷是什么样的？
So there is two types of tents. Now I became expert, by the way.
所以有两种类型的帐篷。顺便说一句，我现在已经成了专家。
I was going to ask you how you know to build tents so quickly.
我正想问你，你是怎么知道搭帐篷搭得这么快的。
So one, I get it through NRC, where I work, and it was with instruction. That was easy. The other one is like wooden sticks with plastic. The hardest part was finding a place, a suitable place to rent a small land, not randomly in the streets, you know? It's agricultural area. It's a bit sandy everywhere.
其中一个是我通过NRC得到的，附带说明书。那很容易。另一个是用木棍和塑料搭建的。最困难的部分是找一个地方，一个合适的租借小块土地的地方，而不是在街上乱搭，你知道吗？这是农业区。到处都是沙子。
So you rent a land? You didn't just--
所以你租了一块地？你不仅仅是——
A lot of airstrikes, wow.
好多次空袭，哇。
I'm sorry, what?
抱歉，你说什么？
No, there was a massive airstrike.
不，发生了一次大规模空袭。
Just now?
就在刚才？
Yeah. Yes. Another airstrike. They're getting crazy somehow, all of this in Khan Yunis.
是的。是的。又一次空袭。它们不知怎么变得疯狂了，这一切都在汗尤尼斯。
The explosions are in Khan Yunis right now?
爆炸现在就在汗尤尼斯吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah. Another one. What's going on? I'll call you in a minute, OK?
是的，是的，是的。又来一个。怎么回事？我待会儿给你打电话，好吗？
No problem. No problem.
没问题。没问题。
I just need to check, OK? Just one minute, I'll call you back.
我只是需要核实一下，好吗？就一分钟，我回电给你。
Take your time. Bye.
慢慢来。再见。
Because it seems really massive there. OK.
因为那里看起来真的很严重。好的。
OK, bye. Hi.
好的，再见。你好。
Hello.
你好。
Hi.
Yes, sorry.
是的，抱歉。
Is everybody OK?
大家都没事吧？
Just wanna make sure that they're still alive. Yeah, they're alive.
只是想确认她们还活着。是的，她们还活着。
Do you literally write, "are you alive?"
你是直接发信息问“你们还活着吗？”吗？
Yeah, it was a funny message from my sister. "Are you alive?"
是的，那是我姐妹发来的一条有趣的短信。“你们还活着吗？”
Wait, that's funny?
等等，那很有趣吗？
Yeah, because I had to send emojis laughing. That's how we are talking, always, even when I'm with them. It's like, OK, we have one more day to live. Let's enjoy it. Maybe two days, OK.
是的，因为我不得不回发大笑的表情符号。这就是我们平时的交流方式，即便我和她们在一起时也是。就像，好吧，我们多活了一天。享受吧。也许两天，好吧。
So you wrote her, are you alive, smiley face?
所以你写给她的，你们还活着吗，加个笑脸？
Yeah.
是的。
Oh, my god. Yeah, and she writes back yes, or she laughs?
噢，天哪。是的，然后她回你是或者笑了吗？
She laughs and said it's a bit calm. A bit calm. OK, I don't know what she means a bit calm, but ya'ani.
她笑了，说有点平静。有点平静。好吧，我不知道她指的有点平静是什么意思，但是，唉。
I'll let you go. I've taken so much of your time.
我让你去忙吧。我占用了你太多时间了。
Thank you so much.
非常感谢。
And tomorrow, what's going to happen is your sisters are going to move?
明天会发生什么，你的姐妹们会搬迁吗？
Yeah, this is going to be the early thing for me to do in the morning because I don't want them to move under the bombing. So I want to evacuate them when it's a bit calm and manageable without risks. So I'll do it in the early morning, but maybe because of this rain-- ah-- I need to assess the situation tomorrow morning. I promised them that we will make decision together this time, tomorrow morning.
是的，这将是我明天早上最早要做的事情，因为我不想让她们在轰炸下搬迁。我想在稍微平静、可控且没有风险的时候撤离她们。所以我会在清晨做，但也许因为这场雨——啊——我需要明天早上评估一下局势。我向她们承诺，这次我们要一起做决定，明天早上。
But you've already made the decision that you want them to go?
但你已经做出了决定，你希望她们走？
Yes.
是的。
[LAUGHS] All right. OK, I hope you have an easy night. And I will check in with you tomorrow.
[笑] 好吧。好的，我希望你有个平安的夜晚。我明天会再联系你。
That's a good phrase, "easy night." [LAUGHS] OK. Inshallah. Thank you. Thank you.
这真是一个好词，“平安的夜晚”。[笑] 好的。因沙安拉（Inshallah）。谢谢。谢谢。
OK, bye.
好的，再见。
Thank you. Bye-bye.
谢谢。再见。
Hi, Yousef?
你好，尤瑟夫？
Hello?
你好？
Did your sisters move today?
你的姐妹们今天搬迁了吗？
Unfortunately, not yet. They were refusing to leave without a bathroom, but today, there were a lot of tanks and airstrikes. No, I promised them that tomorrow it's going to be-- there will be a bathroom tomorrow. I'll make my best to make it happen.
很遗憾，还没有。她们拒绝在没有浴室的情况下离开，但今天有很多坦克和空袭。不，我向她们保证明天会——明天一定会有一个浴室。我会尽我所能让它实现。
I want to jump in and say a little bit about what Yousef doing his best looks like, an incomplete summary of that particular day. He spent the morning trying to track down trucks for the Norwegian Refugee Council, where he works. The trucks were full of aid, things like bedding, tents, buckets for water, that should have arrived at the border, but he couldn't check online if they were there because the system was down and the phones weren't working. So he went in person, wandered around, looking at plate numbers-- could not find the trucks.
我想插一句，尤瑟夫尽他所能的样子，是对那一天不完整的总结。他花了一上午的时间试图追踪挪威难民理事会需要的卡车，他在那儿工作。卡车上装满了援助物资，比如床上用品、帐篷、水桶，本应该到达边境，但他无法在线核实它们是否到了，因为系统瘫痪了，手机也打不通。所以他亲自去，四处徘徊，查看车牌号——没能找到卡车。
Then he went to the market to find medicine for his wife, Manal, who's sick-- could not find medicine. In the midst of all this, he got a call from another relative who was fleeing and needed a place to stay in Rafah. Yes, yes, you can come, Yousef told him. One more tent.
然后他去市场为生病的妻子马纳尔（Manal）找药——没找到药。在这一切过程中，他接到了另一个正在逃难的亲戚的电话，他需要在拉法找个地方住。尤瑟夫告诉他，是的，是的，你可以来。又多了一个帐篷。
Near his sisters' tents, Yousef saw a guy building a bathroom, hired that guy, but he's busy until tomorrow. The bathroom guy told Yousef he needed to find supplies. So Yousef spent hours searching for cement, stones, and a water tank. He found a water tank, but it was in a different part of Gaza, so Yousef paid more than the price of the water tank to get it transported.
在姐妹们的帐篷附近，尤瑟夫看到一个人在建浴室，雇了那个人，但他明天才忙得过来。修浴室的人告诉尤瑟夫他需要找材料。于是尤瑟夫花了几个小时寻找水泥、石头和水箱。他找到了一个水箱，但在加沙的另一个区域，所以尤瑟夫支付了超过水箱价格的费用才把它运过来。
I was picturing a hole in the ground that you were going to build near-- you were going to dig near the tents, but you're building an actual bathroom with water and walls.
我原以为是一个你要在帐篷附近挖的坑，但你在建一个带水和墙的真实浴室。
Yes, actually, that was a condition from my sisters.
是的，实际上，那是我的姐妹们提出的条件。
So is that the first thing for you tomorrow?
那这是你明天第一件要做的事吗？
Definitely, yes. [LAUGHS] It will be happening for sure tomorrow because, ya'ani, a few, two hours ago or less, there was an airstrike near them, and it takes me like half an hour or more just trying to call, trying to call. I couldn't reach anyone. That freaked me out. I cannot handle this situation again.
当然是，是的。[笑] 明天肯定会完成，因为，唉，两个小时前或更短时间前，她们附近发生了空袭，我花了半个多小时试图打电话，试图打通。我联系不到任何人。那让我快疯了。我无法再应付这种情况了。
And I managed to reach my sister, Aseel. And they are fine. There is a lot of gas and a lot of bombing, but we are fine. And this is when we agreed hallas tomorrow you are moving. And I will come to pick you tomorrow.
最后我设法联系上了我的姐妹阿塞尔（Aseel）。她们没事。有很多煤气和轰炸，但我们没事。就在这时，我们达成了一致，明天你们搬迁。我会去接你们。
Oh, you did?
哦，你做到了？
Yeah.
是的。
So she definitely agreed?
所以她真的同意了？
Yeah, yeah. I then-- [NON-ENGLISH] sorry. [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Are we recording something? Because my son is just annoying me. [LAUGHS]
是的，是的。我那时——[非英语] 抱歉。[非英语对话] 我们是在录音吗？因为我儿子真的在烦我。[笑]
That's OK. I like hearing him. How old is he?
没关系。我喜欢听他的声音。他几岁？
2 year and 1/2.
两岁半。
2 and 1/2.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] I'm just asking him to close the door. [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] Last night, I had to stay awake until Ahmed, who cannot sleep without being kissed 1,000 time on his cheeks until he sleep. Sometimes when he feels that I'm tired of kissing him, he gives me his hand to kiss it.
[非英语对话] 我只是叫他关上门。[非英语对话] 昨晚，我不得不熬夜陪艾哈迈德（Ahmed），他睡觉前必须要在脸颊上被亲一千次才睡得着。有时候当他感觉到我亲累了，他会把他的手递给我让我亲。
So that you have it close to you?
这样你就能离你近一点？
Exactly, yeah. He likes to give me some rest sometimes. OK, you can kiss my hand. I don't know how he get this habit, but I don't mind it. And for me, it's OK. [LAUGHS] I'm really grateful for the rain. It start raining. Then that reduced the sound of bombing. And also, you can use-- no, this is thunder strike. So we are lucky today. We can manipulate that, so ya'ani.
没错，是的。他有时喜欢让我休息一下。好吧，你可以亲我的手。我不知道他是怎么养成这个习惯的，但我不在意。对我来说，这还可以。[笑] 我真的很感激这场雨。开始下雨了，这减轻了轰炸的声音。而且你可以用——不，这是雷声。所以我们今天很幸运。我们可以利用这一点，唉。
So you'll tell them in the night if they hear a noise--
所以你会告诉她们如果在晚上听到声音——
Yeah, it's raining. It's raining. It's raining. It's the thunder strike. It's raining. Ya'ani. I don't know. At the beginning, it was a bit easy to convince them that this is fireworks or thunder strike. But then even my daughter, Illya, which is five years old, now can understand that this is airstrike.
是的，在下雨。在下雨。在下雨。那是雷声。在下雨。唉。我不知道。起初，说服她们这是烟花或雷声还比较容易。但后来，甚至连我五岁的女儿伊利亚（Illya）都能理解那是空袭。
Even my son, Ahmed, who is two years and a half, and he can say like bombing, this is from airplane. And he keeps using this word, "gussuff," "gussuff," which means "strikes." And what the hell? That's another massive airstrike.
甚至我两岁半的儿子艾哈迈德，他会说像轰炸，这是飞机发出的。他一直用这个词，“gussuff”，“gussuff”，意思是“轰炸”。搞什么鬼？那又是一次大规模空袭。
Is it close to you?
它离你很近吗？
No. If it was close, you would hear it.
不。如果离得很近，你会听到的。
OK, OK.
好的，好的。
I failed to convince them that this is not a war. And I failed that they know that this is a war at that age. And they see how we are shouting, my sisters are crying. Or it's not enough anymore for my children, when they feel panic from bombing, to run towards us. They start scream without even running towards us because somehow they understood that we don't have that ability to protect them.
我没能说服她们这不是战争。我没能让她们在该年龄段了解这就是战争。她们看到了我们是如何大喊大叫，我的姐妹们在哭。或者当她们感到轰炸的恐慌时，仅仅跑向我们已经不够了。她们开始尖叫，甚至不去跑向我们，因为不知何故，她们理解到我们没有那种保护她们的能力。
And that's something really awful when you understand that your children understand that you cannot protect them. When I start to feel useless in front of my children and when I found that I cannot protect my children, I deeply regret it because-- [SIGHS]
当你意识到你的孩子明白你保护不了他们时，那真的很可怕。当我开始在孩子面前感到无能为力，当我发现我保护不了我的孩子时，我深感后悔，因为——[叹气]
You regret what?
你后悔什么？
What is the meaning as a father? I regret having children here. What is the meaning for me as a father if I cannot protect them?
作为一个父亲意味着什么？我后悔在加沙生孩子。作为一个父亲，如果我保护不了他们，我存在的意义是什么？
You regret having children? Having children in Gaza?
你后悔生孩子？在加沙生孩子？
Yes. Definitely, I regret. I made them. I made that decision. And I had children in Gaza while I know the consequences, but I wasn't imagining that we will go through this, because I am a man of responsibility. I'm responsible for these children to secure their life and future. If I know that they will live through this, I would never, ever even get married here.
是的。我绝对后悔。我生了他们。我做了那个决定。我知道后果还在加沙生了孩子，但我没预料到我们会经历这些，因为我是一个负责任的男人。我有责任保证这些孩子的生活和未来。如果我知道他们会经历这些，我永远、永远不会在这里结婚。
You would never get married. Is that what you said?
你说过你永远不会结婚？那是你说的吗？
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
Yeah. Is a part of that feeling like "I should have known not to do this," or--
是的。那种感觉的一部分是否像是“我应该知道不该这么做”，或者——
It's "I should never have did that decision."
是“我永远不应该做出那个决定”。
Hello?
喂？
Hi, Yousef. Do you have a couple of minutes?
嗨，尤瑟夫。你有几分钟时间吗？
Yeah, of course. Yeah.
是的，当然。是的。
How did today go?
今天过得怎么样？
Oh, it was a really, really long day. Had to start really early and was a lot of things to do.
哦，这是非常、非常漫长的一天。不得不很早开始，有很多事情要做。
Did they move?
她们搬迁了吗？
Yeah.
是的。
They moved?
她们搬过来了？
So I brought them all. Yeah, yeah, they moved.
所以我把她们都带来了。是的，是的，她们搬过来了。
Wow, you did it. Took you--
哇，你做到了。花掉你——
It was really a lot. [LAUGHS] Last night, they were texting me about a lot of bombing. The house next to them was bombed. Another house behind them was bombed. And so they wanted to move. They wanted to go, hallas.
真的做了很多事。[笑] 昨晚，她们一直在给我发短信说有很多轰炸。隔壁的房子被炸了。她们身后的另一所房子也被炸了。所以她们想搬走。她们想走，好了。
You said the house next to them was bombed last night?
你说昨晚隔壁的房子被炸了？
Yes. Yeah, last night was a bit harsh when they started texting me that the bombing is around us. What?
是的。是的，昨晚有点残酷，当她们开始给我发短信说轰炸在周围时。什么？
Yeah. But there was an airstrike that hit a property right next to them?
是的。但有一场空袭击中了她们旁边的一处房产？
Yes, but it's a drone strike. So, OK, we have different types of missiles that the Israelis are using. So there is the F-16, which is warplanes and this American-made weapon that destroy entire neighborhoods. The drones have smaller bombs that destroy a house or half of the house. They were afraid that the bombing might be in the same house because it's four floors, and they are the first one. So that's why they didn't argue me and like, yes, let's move.
是的，但那是无人机袭击。好吧，以色列人使用的是不同类型的导弹。有F-16，那是战机，这种美国制造的武器摧毁了整个街区。无人机有较小的炸弹，摧毁一所房子或半所房子。她们害怕轰炸可能会发生在同一所房子里，因为它有四层楼，她们住在第一层。所以这就是为什么她们没跟我争论，而是说，是的，我们搬吧。
Did you think about going in the night?
你有想过在晚上过去吗？
Yeah, I told them, I'm coming.
是的，我告诉她们，我来了。
You texted back, I'm coming?
你回复短信说，我来了？
Yes, and they were freaking out that I will come. And my wife prevented me. My sisters were texting me, do not come. There is a lot of bombing in the street in front of the house. Do not come.
是的，她们因为我要过去而吓坏了。我妻子阻止了我。我的姐妹们给我发短信说，别过来。房子前面的街上有很多轰炸。别过来。
Yousef waited till the sun came up and then drove to Khan Yunis. He says on his way there, he could hear gunfire and explosions all around him.
尤瑟夫等到太阳升起，然后开车去了汗尤尼斯。他说在去那里的路上，他能听到周围的枪声和爆炸声。
The first thing I did in the morning is, I went there, pack up in the car my sisters and their children. And I came and then I sent another car, like a small van, small bus, so I can have the bags and everything and my brothers-in-law.
我早上做的第一件事就是去那里，把我的姐妹和她们的孩子装进车里。然后我开车回来，之后我派了另一辆车，像一辆小货车，小巴士，这样我就可以把行李和所有东西以及我的妹夫们带上。
Was there a part of you that felt a little frustrated? Like, I told you guys you should have come earlier? I didn't want it to get to this?
有没有一部分的你感到有点沮丧？比如，我告诉过你们应该早点来的？我不希望变成这样？
That's exactly what the first thing I said today when I met them.
这正是今天我见到她们时说的第一句话。
[LAUGHS] That was how you greeted them?
[笑] 那就是你打招呼的方式？
Yeah.
是的。
What did you say?
你说了什么？
The first thing was like, I told you. We don't want to-- 'cause there was a lot of bombing, a lot of tanks. I told you before, we don't need to run away under shelling and bombing. But now we did it. Hallas. Every time, it had to be the same situation.
第一件事就是，我告诉过你们。我们不想——因为当时有很多轰炸，很多坦克。我之前告诉过你们，我们不需要在炮火和轰炸下逃跑。但现在我们做到了。好了。每次都必须是同样的情况。
So overnight, you're worried about their survival and you're panicked, and you want to drive to get them in the middle of the night, but in the morning, you greet them with, "I told you so. This is what I said was going to happen."
所以一夜之间，你担心她们的生存，你感到恐慌，你想在大半夜开车去接她们，但在早上，你迎接她们的却是，“我早就说过了。这就是我说的会发生的事。”
Yeah. I was blaming them. [LAUGHS] So there is no discussion we are leaving.
是的。我是在责怪她们。[笑] 所以没有讨论，我们必须离开。
So you didn't hug them and cry and say, I'm so glad you survived. You said--
所以你没有拥抱她们哭着说，我真高兴你们活了下来。你说——
No.
没有。
--get in the car.
——上车。
No, we have a different type of relation. It's not about hugging them. I was laughing. You should have died. I should be in the morgue now. [LAUGHS] This is how I am with my sisters.
没有，我们有不同类型的关系。这不是拥抱她们的那种。我当时在笑。你们本应该死的。我现在应该在停尸房了。[笑] 这就是我和我姐妹相处的方式。
And did they laugh? What did they say back?
她们笑了吗？她们回了什么？
Hadir was like, ah, you know. Actually, they will start to give me orders quickly. You need to talk to our cousin, Amajid, because he was hosting us. You need to invite him. You have to talk to him nicely and push to bring them with us because they take care of us for a long time. Now we have to repay them. Also, go to our Uncle Ayman because they wanted to have invited by you, not us. It's a bit weird. Like, OK, I'll do this, and you pack the luggage, and you'll do that. And they refused to leave before cleaning everything.
哈迪尔（Hadir）当时说，啊，你知道的。其实，她们很快就开始给我下命令。你需要和我们的表兄阿马吉德（Amajid）谈谈，因为是他收留了我们。你需要邀请他。你得好好跟他谈谈，力争把他和我们一起带过来，因为他们照顾我们很长一段时间。现在我们必须报答他们。还有，去找我们的叔叔艾曼（Ayman），因为他们希望被你邀请，而不是我们。这有点奇怪。就像，好吧，我会做这些，你们去打包行李，你们去做那个。而且她们拒绝在打扫干净一切之前离开。
They wouldn't leave without cleaning the house?
她们不打扫干净房子就不走？
Yep, cleaning the house, kitchen, bathrooms.
是的，打扫房子、厨房、浴室。
Even though you're fleeing bombing?
尽管你们正在逃避轰炸？
Yes, because they will-- yeah, that was actually weird from them, but this is how they think. And I really respect it because we leave it better than the way we have. This is how we show respect. And we had to clean.
是的，因为她们会——是的，这确实很奇怪，但这就是她们的思维方式。我真的很尊重这一点，因为我们离开时让它比我们拥有它时更好。这就是我们表达尊重的方式。而且我们必须打扫。
And then you left.
然后你们就走了。
Yeah.
是的。
OK.
好的。
Then we left.
然后我们走了。
What did it--
那——
And it was the first time for them since the beginning of the war to see the sea.
而且这是她们自战争开始以来第一次看到大海。
Oh.
哦。
And they were very, very excited and happy.
她们非常、非常兴奋和开心。
How did they respond to the tents when you showed them where they're staying?
她们对你向她们展示的帐篷住所作何反应？
I was expecting that they will be like, eh, it's not nice, but they were happy. It's like, OK, it's nice. It's good.
我以为她们会说，唉，这不好，但她们很开心。就像，好吧，这很棒。这很好。
Did you feel nervous?
你感到紧张吗？
Yeah, yeah, yeah. I want them to see that-- to prove for them that I did my best. And I was checking on them inside the tents. What do you think? It's warm. There is two layers for the tent, one for if it's rain and one inside. I was trying to convince them as, you know these sale people who is trying to convince you to buy something?
是的，是的，是的。我想要她们看到——向她们证明我尽了全力。我在帐篷里检查她们。你们觉得怎么样？很暖和。帐篷有两层，一层防雨，一层在里面。我试图说服她们，就像你知道那些试图说服你买东西的推销员一样？
Uh-huh. That was you?
嗯嗯。那是你？
That's exactly what I was. That was me today. Yeah, it's nice, good. We'll do with the bathroom here. We'll get something there. Here, we can turn on the fire. And I was like, oh, one minute. I'll get you internet tomorrow, and I will get you lights here. Our neighbors have a solar panel. He will connect us some lights. Yeah, I was doing that sale man. And they were happy.
那正是我。今天那就是我。是的，这很棒，很好。我们会在这里解决浴室问题。我们在那里弄点东西。这里，我们可以生火。我说，哦，一分钟。我明天给你们弄互联网，我会给你们带灯来。我们的邻居有太阳能电池板。他会给我们连接一些灯。是的，我当时就是那个推销员。她们很开心。
They were? Did they give you the response you wanted?
她们是吗？她们给你想要的反应了吗？
Yeah, it's like, yeah, it's nice. Also, in our way coming, we went through one of the camps that people are just building tents in the streets. And they saw how miserable the situation is, so. And I meant to go there before taking them to our place.
是的，就像，是的，这很棒。而且，在我们来的路上，我们经过了一个人们正在街上搭建帐篷的营地。她们看到了情况是多么悲惨。我是特意在那之前带她们去我们的地方的。
You did it on purpose?
你是故意这么做的？
Exactly, because I want them to see how people are living to prove for them that I did my best managing what I could. And when I met them today, I found out that they didn't eat for two days. They only eat rice. So first thing I was thinking about, like, preparing a really big meal for them, and they were surprised I had barbecues and kebab. And I was like, no, no, no.
没错，因为我想让她们看到人们是怎样生活的，向她们证明我尽了我所能做的一切。今天见到她们时，我发现她们两天没吃饭了。她们只吃了米饭。所以我想到的第一件事就是准备一顿非常丰盛的饭菜，她们很惊讶我有烤肉和烤串。我说，不，不，不。
So they had a meal? You had a meal together?
所以她们吃了一顿饭？你们一起吃了饭？
A very big one. It was very expensive one, but I was like, OK, I'll feed you until you've had more than enough. [LAUGHS]
非常丰盛的一餐。非常昂贵，但我当时想，好吧，我要喂你们直到你们吃得饱饱的。[笑]
Wow.
哇。
And so after fasting for two days, it worked to provide them with something really good.
所以禁食两天后，为她们提供一些真正的好东西很有效。
Did they appreciate it?
她们感激了吗？
Ooh, a lot. They were very happy. I was very happy also having this meal. [LAUGHS]
噢，很多。她们非常开心。我也很开心能吃上这顿饭。[笑]
[PHONE RINGING]
[电话铃响]
Hello, Chana.
你好，查娜。
Hi, Yousef. How are you doing?
你好，尤瑟夫。你好吗？
Good, all good.
好，一切都好。
This call, five days after I started speaking to Yousef, was the first time I talked to him when he was not agonizing over his sisters and how to get them out of Khan Yunis. They were there, their first day in their new place, settling in. There still wasn't a bathroom, but Yousef had asked a neighbor if his family could use their bathroom until his was up and running. He went to work that morning, made it a couple hours into the day when he got a call from his youngest sister, Aseel.
这通电话是在我开始和尤瑟夫通话五天后，这是我第一次在他没有为他的姐妹们如何离开汗尤尼斯而苦恼时和他交谈。她们在那儿，在她们的新住处的第一天，安顿下来了。虽然还没有浴室，但尤瑟夫已经问过邻居是否可以在他自己的浴室建好之前使用邻居的。那天早上他去工作，工作了几个小时后，接到了他最小的姐妹阿塞尔（Aseel）的电话。
It's too complicated.
太复杂了。
Wait. Tell me what happened with your sister.
等等。告诉我你姐妹那边发生了什么。
So Aseel today wanted to go to the bathroom, and she waited. So there is, in the land next to us, they have a bathroom, and they're friends of mine. And my neighbor is hosting more than 60 people. So they have to wait in line to earn this bathroom. It's a single bathroom.
所以阿塞尔今天想去上厕所，她等了。在我们隔壁的那块地里，他们有一个浴室，他们是我的朋友。我的邻居收留了60多人。所以她们得排队才能用这个浴室。这是一个单间浴室。
Oh, wow. How pregnant is she? When is she due?
哦，哇。她怀孕几个月了？预产期是什么时候？
So she is at the seventh month, about to finish it. And she cannot wait. She's pregnant, and it's a bit embarrassing for her. And so she starts to cry. And then she called me.
她怀孕七个月了，快满了。她等不及了。她怀孕了，这对她来说有点尴尬。所以她开始哭。然后她给我打了电话。
While she was in line?
她在排队的时候？
So she cried several times, and she were hopeless. Then she started to cry and decided to go back to Khan Yunis
她哭了多次，感到绝望。然后她开始哭，决定回汗尤尼斯。
[GASPS]
[倒吸一口凉气]
She decided that, and she called me, and she told me I'm leaving to Khan Yunis now. Oh, that's changed the day. I had to go back [LAUGHS] to meet my sister, take her to the bathroom, spend an hour or more. I went, I stopped the line.
她做了那个决定，她给我打电话，告诉我我现在要回汗尤尼斯。哦，那改变了这一天。我不得不回去[笑]见我的姐妹，带她去浴室，花了一个小时多。我去了，我停下了队伍。
How did the 60 people waiting respond to that?
那60个排队的人有什么反应？
It went OK. There was someone inside, and I told them no one is getting inside. No one goes to the bathroom, hallas, until my sister finished.
还可以。里面有人，我告诉他们谁也不许进去。谁也不许去洗手间，直到我姐妹用完。
Was she seriously thinking about going back to Khan Yunis?
她是真的考虑回汗尤尼斯吗？
I don't think so. It shows me that she needs me. I need to find a solution now. She's above the limits.
我不这么认为。这表明她需要我。我现在得找个解决方案。她已经超出极限了。
The whole week, Yousef had been telling me that he needed his family close to him so he could think rationally about what was going on around him. Now, they're here with all the joy and irritation that comes with having family close by.
这一整周，尤瑟夫一直告诉我，他需要家人在他身边，这样他才能理性地思考周围发生的事情。现在，她们在这里了，伴随着拥有家人在身边的所有喜悦和烦恼。
They're together in Rafah. They've moved from the very north of Gaza all the way down, the furthest south they can go. There is nowhere else. They're at the bottom edge of the Gaza Strip, on the border with Egypt. Yousef can think a little bit about what's next.
她们在拉法团聚了。她们从加沙的最北端一路南下，到了她们能去的的最南端。没别的地方了。她们就在加沙地带的边缘，和埃及的边境上。尤瑟夫可以思考一下接下来的打算了。
What makes it a bit harder on me that I've been outside Gaza. I know how it looks like outside. First time I've been out outside of Gaza was last year.
让我感到难过的一点是我去过加沙外面。我知道外面是什么样子。我第一次去加沙外面是去年。
And it was for your job to--
那是为了你的工作去——
Yes, to Norway with NRC. And when I arrived to Oslo, Norway, and the airport, they stamp my passport, and she said, welcome.
是的，和挪威难民理事会去了挪威。当我到达挪威奥斯陆机场时，他们在我的护照上盖了章，她说，欢迎。
And it was weird for me. There is no interrogation. They're not going to question me, anything. They are not going to look for me as a terrorist. And they're not going to check my bags or my body or my-- they just allow me to enter, and it feels weird. It feels weird in a way that I want them to check me and interrogate me. Like, this is not you. This is not the usual. Come on, guys. You have to--
那对我来说很奇怪。没有审讯。他们不会审问我，什么都不会。他们不会把我当作恐怖分子来寻找。他们不会检查我的行李或我的身体或我的——他们只是允许我进入，感觉很奇怪。感觉很奇怪，以至于我想要他们检查我并审问我。就像，这不像你。这不是通常的情况。拜托，伙计们。你们必须——
You have to do your job.
你们得做你们的工作。
--ask me some questions. Yeah, come on. You have to ask me something. You have to ask me where I live or whatever. Who is my neighbor, or what I do, or what's my relation with the militant groups in Gaza. You have to ask me about anything. Come on.
——问我一些问题。是的，拜托。你们得问我点什么。你们得问我住哪里或者别的什么。谁是我的邻居，或者我是做什么的，或者我和加沙武装团体的关系是什么。你们得问我任何事情。拜托。
And I saw how the world is massive. For me, Gaza was a bit big. Gaza is very, very narrow piece of land. And for me, it was huge. But when I saw the world outside of Gaza, I was like, guys, we are living in a small neighborhood.
我看到了世界是多么广阔。对我来说，加沙有点大。加沙是一块非常、非常狭窄的土地。对我来说，它很大。但当我看到加沙以外的世界时，我想，伙计们，我们住在一个小街区里。
What felt different?
什么感觉不同？
Everything is different. Cannot imagine how I was feeling when I saw the first time an airplane or an airport. I felt like I'm four years old.
一切都不同。无法想象当我第一次看到飞机或机场时我有什么感觉。我觉得自己像四岁一样。
And I was saying always, I'm Gazan more than any Gazan here because I've never been outside. And when I went outside, I understood how it feels. I saw how people are living their life. And I totally understand why they don't really care about us. They are busy with their lives.
我总是说，我是加沙人，比这里的任何加沙人都更加沙，因为我从未出去过。当我出去时，我了解了那是什么感觉。我看到了人们是怎样过他们的生活的。我完全理解为什么他们真的不关心我们。他们忙于自己的生活。
There is an entire generation never been outside of Gaza. And what my children, what they have been through is something unimaginable, and they don't deserve that. What is the world expecting from this generation after 15 years when they lived through all of this?
整整一代人从未去过加沙以外。我的孩子们经历过的事情是不可想象的，他们不应该遭受这些。世界对这一代人在15年后经历过这一切后有什么期待？
What do you expect?
你有什么期待？
More violence. How they are going to think rationally?
更多的暴力。他们怎么能理性地思考？
Do you worry about that with your own children?
你担心你自己的孩子吗？
I made that decision. And when this war finish, if we survive, I will take them outside. I'm not allowing my children to go through this situation again.
我做出了那个决定。如果这场战争结束了，如果我们幸存下来，我会带他们出去。我不允许我的孩子再次经历这种情况。
You want to leave?
你想离开？
[SIGHS] It's-- I know it's going to be really, really difficult. Gaza is part of us, ya'ani. And I know it's-- but, ah, it's really hard to think about that now, to be honest, in the middle of the war. But I made a decision that without thinking about it, they are not going to stay here. So it's 10:30 now, so--
[叹气] 我知道这会非常、非常困难。加沙是我们的一部分，唉。我知道——但这，啊，老实说，在战争中很难考虑那个。但我做出了一个决定，而不必思考它，他们不会留在这里。现在是10点30分了，所以——
You want to go to bed.
你想睡觉了。
--it's pretty--
——这很——
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, and at least it's gone now. I could catch some before they start shooting or something.
是的，至少现在消失了。在他们开始射击或其他什么之前，我能抓紧时间睡一会儿。
Yeah, you should do that.
是的，你应该那样做。
OK.
好的。
Have a nice night. Salaam alechum. Bye.
祝你晚安。真主安宁（Salaam alechum）。再见。
Yousef Hammash in Gaza, talking to Chana Joffe-Walt. This story was produced by Nancy Updike, edited by me and Nancy and Emanuele Berry; mixed by Katherine Rae Mondo; fact-checked by Jane Ackermann. Special thanks today to Shaina Low, Nabil Shawkat, Hany Hawasly, Anas Baba, Brian Castner, Dror Sadot, and Mark Garlasco. The show comes to you from WBEZ Chicago and PRX, the Public Radio International. We'll be back this weekend, just a couple of days from now, with a new episode for you.
在加沙的尤瑟夫·哈马什，与查娜·乔夫-沃尔特对话。这个故事由南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）制作，我和南希以及伊曼纽尔·贝里（Emanuele Berry）编辑；凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）混音；简·阿克曼（Jane Ackermann）事实核查。特别感谢谢娜·洛（Shaina Low）、纳比尔·肖卡特（Nabil Shawkat）、哈尼·哈瓦斯利（Hany Hawasly）、阿纳斯·巴巴（Anas Baba）、布莱恩·卡斯特纳（Brian Castner）、德罗尔·萨多特（Dror Sadot）和马克·加拉斯科（Mark Garlasco）。该节目来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台PRX。我们将在这个周末，也就是几天后，带着新一期节目回来。